and finally new rule historians have to
stop telling us
everything's going to be okay because
we've been here before
with all due respect we haven't
you can't watch a day of cable news
anymore without seeing prominent
historians telling us calm down america
has survived
bad times and we have the civil war the
depression
pearl harbor 911 disco
but trust me my historian friends i've
read your books on american history and
this guy
ain't in any of them
george w bush was a walking disaster
area but he believed in democracy
so much so he tried to export it to iraq
whereas trump believes in oligarchy so
much he's trying to import it from
russia
yes previous presidents declared war
but never on reality
you got to admit that's kind of new and
look i love historians i watch the
history channel like most guys watch
pornhub
in college i majored in history and who
didn't love high school history it was
always a 50
chance the teacher would be hungover and
just show a movie
but stop trying to calm us down right
now
you know when it's okay to yell fire in
a theater when it's on fire
last week
last week trump's stun-in-law said of
trump he's a black swan
a black swan is something we've never
seen before
that defies all previous expectations
that's what we're dealing with a black
swan
with a mushroom penis
[Applause]
and when i look at the trump family it
feels a lot like it has a lot less
in common with this family than with
this family
this attitude that america is like a cat
it always lands on its feet i don't buy
it
i don't buy that just because something
didn't happen before it can't happen
now rome didn't fall and didn't fall
and didn't fall and then it fell
gonorrhea has been around for a long
time and we could always kill it with
penicillin
but now there's drug resistant super
gonorrhea and we can't
was incivility bad in other times in our
history i'm sure it was i've heard the
anecdotes
i know that during a brawl in the house
chamber in 1798
congressman matthew lyon of vermont
tried to beat roger griswold of
connecticut with a pair of iron tongues
i don't give a [ __ ] this isn't two
gentlemen slapping each other in the
face with gloves this is a slow
moving coup this is the head of the
federal government
calling the american citizens that make
up the free press
the enemy of the people
and that's why here on our final show
before the election i want to talk
directly to
the millennials and to generation
instagram
or whatever they're calling you
we need you we need you like you need
your anti-anxiety meds
[Music]
not to protest or to post something we
need you to
actually vote because historically
you are the least likely to i get it
you're young and young people aren't big
on planning for the future
that's why we have laser tattoo removal
[Music]
but we need you to turn out in
unprecedented numbers and we know you
can
look at the march for our lives that's
that's how you should approach voting
this year as a march for your life
it's your future not mine
but to paraphrase the farmer's insurance
guy
i know a thing or two because i've seen
a thing or two
and to paraphrase the allstate guy
you're not in good hands
getting this moment wrong and not
participating will be just
like your student loan debt it will
haunt you for the rest of your life
getting this moment wrong you can say
goodbye to reproductive rights to
legalize pot
possibly to gay marriage and definitely
to what's left of the environment
if trump wins he will cast it as a
complete
endorsement of his most undemocratic
behavior
if you're 18 and that happens you stand
a very real chance of not
living in a western style democracy for
part or all of your life
yes it can happen here if historians
want to look at an example of
we've been here before look at this
picture
this isn't nuremberg in 1934
it's madison square garden in liberal
new york city
in 1934 and here's the garden in 1939.
after hitler had already done some
pretty awful things and yet 22
000 americans were cheering him on i'm
not saying trump is hitler
hitler volunteered for the army
but trump is a wanna-be dictator and he
does have a knack
of getting what he wants to be
so mark tuesday november 6 down mark it
on your calendar like your brett
kavanaugh planning to get shit-faced
because tuesday is winner go home
for democracy